we're gonna go back to the phones next
is our caller from the 7 to 7 area code
caller from 7 to 7 go ahead hey David
this is Monica I'm from it's not
terribly awful part of Florida and I
have a few questions you may have more
information on this and I do last night
I just thought briefly on television
that I guess that news anchors were
floating the idea that Trump may pardon
Cohen I haven't read anything else about
it and that's literally the only thing I
heard so fast if you've heard anything
else about it or if you think it's
pretty sort of likely or so Trump more
important cause I think that make things
worse there's a sort of general
possibility that Trump will pardon any
and/or all of the people that end up
getting sentenced convicted in
connection with whatever it is that went
on as part of his campaign and even
administration Cohen specifically Flynn
there's the idea that mana for now is
just going to basically clam up take
whatever he gets
and then Trump will pardon him I don't
know I mean you know Trump himself has
said we've heard reports that Trump was
asking about his pardon power there have
been comments from Trump about that
we'll see at some point in the future
I don't know that listen if he's going
to do that there's very few limits on
presidential pardon power there's a bit
of a legal question as to whether the
president can use the pardon to sort of
help himself but there's divergent legal
views on that and there's a legal view
that's very absolutist which just says
the president's pardon power is absolute
it doesn't matter what the underlying
motivation is for issuing a pardon even
if it's protecting himself so I don't
know that there's that much value in
evaluating the likelihood of specific
pardons but I think generally speaking
there's no question he will pardon
people he pardons Scooter Libby he
pardoned Joe Arpaio and that's a real
possibility here and I have one more
question sure do you believe that there
is a PP tape and if there is can you
believe say like down the line maybe
even years to come that the American
Songbook will actually know real details
of it
or I think anybody wants to see it I
mean listen here's the thing here
there's a there's an in-between between
there's a pee-pee tape and nothing ever
happened with Trump and prostitutes in a
Russian hotel room and that's that
something happened but it wasn't
recorded right and that's a possibility
that's not really being discussed that
much I have no idea where there's a
pee-pee tape what I do know is that
trumps already been caught in some lies
related to the existence of that tape
that's really really a turd it might
just be the trumpet in Russia anyone
exactly saying he didn't overnight but
he actually spent two nights there I
don't know if there was a pee-pee tape I
mean do you think that there is one
probably there's a piece I believe he
probably did something that the Russians
may have some sort of leverage right
yeah I mean I think it's clearly every
year there's some weird reason that he's
behaving the way he's behaving whether
it's because they have urine fetish
recordings of him or not I couldn't
really tell you thank you so much for
the call I really appreciate it
okay thank you all right great to hear
from people in Florida whether it's the
good part of Florida or bad part yeah
what part of Florida is she from Miami
that's the best part that's the best
part of Florida if you ask me a for sure